[Music]
in Forever Young and then a jay-z song
yeah oh it's like a 80s yeah damn it's a
remix yeah yeah how am I supposed to
know if you're asking for the thing
we're probably gonna give you the
original real super defensive they're a
little weird today
all the time I was just simply excuse me
[Laughter]
thing when somebody gets a little add so
we just go whoa wait he got mad cuz you
was like you filming in my store you'd
ask permission you hurt my feeling my
bad dawg
I just wanted to promote your store do
you go round first and then you say what
you gotta say or do you say and then go
you say anything there's like what the
[ __ ] your problem
whoa rare I added my own flair to it
though I like that bye
unagi a woman injects herself with 3.5
million year-old bacteria to stay young
we did an article about this bacteria
before where people were experimenting
with it mm-hmm and it works it keeps you
young I don't research it at all so I'm
pretty sure I heard it from the JK news
well I don't remember that we talked
about it do you do you frequent Facebook
oh maybe that's where I am that's what
happens to me too I think I hear it I'm
like yeah and then I'm like
I get excited because when I remember
[ __ ] it's like a book yeah it's like a
point like at night and you're just
looking at Facebook no no it's such a
huge achievement for geo to remember
something that's why she needs to
celebrate the [ __ ] clock
i we main book yes this 45 year old
German actress German oh wait wait wait
whatever mote mmm attack I had no idea
it caught us off guard like I thought
this gonna be like some Chinese [ __ ]
engaging [ __ ] okay like a white blond
lady from Beverly Hills or something
yeah so she's been injecting yourself
with bacillus F which is a three point
five million year old bacteria from the
Siberian permafrost where did where did
she inject into her bloodstream Oh
straight into the bloodstream damn scary
well I wonder if she's gonna get powers
so this woman and she goes by the
moniker manaus and she describes herself
herself as a human lab rat because she's
the first person in the world to inject
herself into it like directly into her
bloodstream with it what's the thought
process behind this she's all vanity
she's just trying to say no but like how
does like bacteria make her young
we should have their own like Chinese
way of thinking no this is actual this
is some really rare obviously like super
rare bacteria this was first discovered
by Russian scientists in the permafrost
of north western Russia back in 2009 and
it was hailed as a scientific sensation
and so they're saying that the bacteria
is DNA was unlocked in 2015 by tima
researchers and they said that they they
claim that this bacteria is like unlike
any other cells but they've come across
before because it showed no signs of age
oh okay in it yeah and so they're just
saying that it could it could possibly
be the key to eternal youth I can see
why show us I wouldn't mind looking
young and still dying I mean like I
still I still my life span is still 80
or something or 1925 all do until your
head I'm cool with that
just like but what if this shortens your
life span so you look like you're 20 but
you die when you're 35 oh [ __ ] that dude
I want to live as long as possible
who's gonna [ __ ] annoy you for the
rest of your life what's the signal for
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you cat me is it this oh
[ __ ] you don't comment chickadees is
gonna evolve into like no speaking it's
all yeah so if you guys are wondering
how she even got her hands on this
bacteria she got it from the head of the
geochronology department at Moscow State
University they [ __ ] yeah by this
doctor unnamed doctor and totally broke
a lot bro sorry I said it wrong looked
and it's only available there well it's
not available was to Rajskub
brooch - looks good better dr. bachlin
reactors okay wait how old is she 14 at
40 weeks or anything oh no
that girl looks like she's 90 years old
it's not work JLo's 45 right well she's
been obsessed by sixer jurian like oh
she don't [ __ ] it up
she's never gonna know my god she's 45
she looks 60 she [ __ ] no but she is
saying that since she started injecting
herself she has been feeling like way
better like she's Benjamin Button yes to
her injections like those pictures
that's true I need some of that [ __ ]
well is she saying that her skin is now
soft as a baby's bottom and you can't
really see it in the photos but if you
see me in person you can see that there
are no marks or blemishes I've never
felt better I have never slept better
deeper or longer that's wise yeah and so
that doctor that's giving her this
bacteria he he takes it orally sure
right and so he's saying that so both of
them take this time honey would anything
know um damn that's [ __ ] not what
good no it's cuz I can't you be like
just [ __ ] with her and just taking
her money oh yeah for sure
that's my last question I was gonna ask
is it regulated I'd go cuz if this is
the Fountain of Youth I'm taking it now
we have to get your hand on me well this
is doctor cuz he's been taking it orally
for a minute before he even gave it to
her has he felt any positive effects
felt like he could do windmills again
could be boy like he did in the eighties
he's all bothered by [ __ ] flares
again no I want to see this [ __ ] hey
Bundy so apparently the doctors saying
that he now he feels better than ever so
yeah but that's a lot of things that can
make you feel better than ever
Puppis oh yeah that's true but even the
doctor like advised her to not inject it
directly interpret blood stream she on
her own so you're supposed to take it
orally but she's like the doctor takes
it orally and so she's the first one to
put into recta but don't you want to
listen to the top yeah where did you get
that idea from just herself so they're
saying that there are no there is no
knowing what effects this might have
long-term but no risk no success says
this woman yeah but there's still
science [ __ ] what's up I got a headache
so I'm gonna snort Tylenol there have
been previous reports claiming that it
has been this bacteria has been injected
into living organisms like human blood
cells mice and crops and that the
results were encouraging with the
animals living longer than expected so
you know what bacteria I believe in like
probiotics I believe that [ __ ] it's real
they picked the worst picture all she
needs is a little bit of Yakult
she looks six all my dad she looks so
bad she got seaweed her why she looking
like Michael Jackson with titties she's
gonna watch this and be so sad if you're
watching this we're just joking this is
a comedy channel you're beautiful if
you're watching this I'm not joking
you're a monster
okay you're beautiful I'm kidding I
don't know I don't know how to feel
anymore you know what sucks there's
people like this they already have a
problem with plastic surgery and all
that and then like so as you said she
was an actor right so maybe she was the
hot girl that just kept holding on to
her hotness and she can't age gracefully
because she just wants to be the sex
symbol yeah she's already spent $50,000
on plastic surgery
con dude it's not even worth it if you
wanted to keep your skin you will just
go to Korea they got a bunch of [ __ ] for
you do surgery this like place you can
go to LA for that [ __ ] true I bet she
started when she was like 20 also and
then she already started [ __ ] it up
yes for 20 years so yeah it's just 25 Oh
father you see I called it I mean she
was pretty hideous already or she was
really hot and like Joe is saying she
want to maintain it so she's like before
I get wrinkles let me just get you know
Botox you know just to prevent all that
and she started to [ __ ] her she just
needed some probiotics man but [ __ ] I
but I stand by that [ __ ] probiotics
water water sleep yeah good genetics you
can't beat that we go somewhere human
every once in a while stay positive I'm
like I'm waiting for the [ __ ] pill
that immediately gives you the results
as if you ran six miles and waiting for
two hours but what steroids though you
still have to stay active though depends
some of them are really some of them are
some very harsh and we're very like
they'll change you like crazy some just
a little adjustment there's different
ones I think I'm just scared of the
baldness that comes with it with a lot
of people afterwards or the development
of titties they're not so bad he's got a
lower back problems every now and then
but the hair thing if the hair goes like
too early I'm okay if I'm all like
around like 45 or whatever but at this
simple age sometimes you get impotence
too you can't get oh for sure if I go
bald like in the next two years you
better believe I'm gonna be a barbell
everyday cuz that's the only way you
counteract all this is if you get buff
you're gonna look like a toe right up
what is it that the most interest thing
you've ever heard and your whole entire
life I don't even know what you guys
just talked about but anyways please
subscribe for more random videos more
funny content and more hahaha poopoo in
your pants stuff go ahead subscribe and
for more videos right